this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your relationships your
mental health your work
you your money this is a show about your
life it's called the ramsey show but
it's all about you the phone number here
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five as we celebrate
baby steps millionaires being number one
book in the nation
uh john i think it's a good idea to stop
and pause and remind people
that uh very very few people become
wealthy
being crooks
most people build wealth
by steady saving
and by being good
people people of character i disagree
dave i heard that on the news that evil
people
are also rich people and vice versa you
read that in the in the newspaper did
you yeah
because everything that's on the news or
the internet or the newspaper is
absolutely true so you're telling me
dave that there are people who have
worked and saved and provided value to
their communities and to their country
and to their neighbors
and they have money too it turns out
that that is the
the statistically
significant most high probability of
becoming wealthy is providing service
because if you feed somebody one
hamburger and you make a dolla
um you made a dollar and they got a
hamburger and they're happy they got a
hamburger in their belly
and uh
if you feed so i'll tell you a guy i
talked to the other day
our team talked to i didn't talk to him
is the guy that started the company
jelly bellies
those gourmet jelly beans i know what
they are he's brought a lot of joy
to people
now he's he's he's an evil rich person
right by selling and giving great joy
with jelly beans
to a lot of people and uh i'm telling
you man i i don't know who the gummy
bear guy is but you genuinely have been
served by him jelly bellies i don't know
if i've been i'm not sure who the donut
guy is but i've been served by him yeah
mr mr cream
yeah
of the krispy kreme uh foundation thank
you yeah we support that foundation
and uh or the duncan mr duncan either
one i love the jelly belly oh man so hey
here's the thing if you provide service
uh to one person you're gonna make
one
dollar or one amount of money if you
precise provide service to
millions people you're gonna make
millions of dollars
and you didn't steal any of it evil rich
people is a bunch of crap it's a lie
here's an example my friend mark cuban
and um
i can actually dial mark's phone number
and he actually will answer we have very
short conversations because he and i are
just alike we don't talk on the phone
hey what see
that's it yeah yeah done no i email him
sometimes and he emails me back no yep
or maybe later we'll talk later or
something you know that kind of stuff so
big big deep in in-depth relationships
but uh um
but he has uh to to his credit
billionaire this from uh this on npr oh
god
uh billionaire investor and dallas
mavericks owner mark cuban has launched
an online pharmacy for generic drugs
that promises steep discounts over
traditional distributors the mark cuban
cost plus drug company announced opening
its online pharmacy wednesday the
pharmacy says it will bypass the health
care industry middlemen
and help consumers avoid high drug
prices by charging manufacturers prices
plus a flat
15 percent markup and pharmacist fee
all drugs are priced at cost plus 15
percent
sign up and share your thoughts and
experiences with us cuban tweeted last
week
cuban's pharmacy says it will negotiate
drug prices directly with manufacturers
to lower its costs for consumers one
drug for diabetes patients sells for
three dollars and ninety cents for a
30-day supply compared for retail at
twenty dollars a thirty count of um i
can't pronounce it which is used to
treat leukemia and other cancers goes
for as low as 17 and 10 cents at cuban's
pharmacy compared to 2
500
instead of 17
at other pharmacies now cubans going to
make another billion doing this and he
will have helped
millions and millions of people
get drugs for 17 instead of 2 500
what's evil about this
you literally have a billionaire here
that that by looking at this article
looks like he is attempting to provide a
public good somebody who says i've got
the money and resources i'm sick of
people i know who have lesser
less less economic uh buying power than
i do
not be able to afford their drug i'm
solving this problem and i'm gonna make
a lot of money why why is that i don't
understand the opposing force there
there it's it's um if i'm happy you
can't be because you took up because i
took up all the happiness yeah it's like
there's a
game like it's a joy
yeah it's a fixed pie if you make a
bunch of money that means someone else
didn't that's not how money works
oh man rabbi lapin says money is more
like candles than cake
if you get a big slice of cake that
means someone else gets a smaller slice
no that's not how money works so it's
more like candles when you light a
candle your candle is not diminished and
you light another candle and you light
another candle and you light another
counter and then you got christmas eve
service oh huh
so this is mark cubans here's a here's
something that just happened just a few
minutes ago
um
i went and
did a
talk with a
guy who owns a couple of car dealerships
in kentucky and met with this team
around the tornado
right he was right on the tornado he
asked me to come up there talk about
crisis talk about stuff talk about
trauma talk about trauma how do we move
past this and his first time his group
got back together and as a part of that
conversation i was asking and individual
people what are they what's what's
something that's real and tangible
that's going on in your life right now
somebody stood up and talked about a
problem with their home they don't have
a home yeah and
um they just bought a new home and then
a sale of their old home fell through it
was just a mess
and
this owner quietly said he called his
wife and said i'm gonna buy a house
today
and i he didn't elaborate further ended
up buying that house and said i'm gonna
find something good to do with this
house and thought i'll flip it whatever
then somebody in this and when the
tornadoes came through
he was able to provide housing for a
family that's been displaced and now has
the idea of i'm gonna keep this thing
and definitely i can just use this to
serve
because people need a place to stay
whether it's two months five months one
year and now i've got an opportunity to
help them and that's a 30-year game of
somebody who's been stewarding their
money taking care of their people has
got a heart of a servant and now has the
resources to say i'm going to help you
and i'm going to help them i'm going to
serve my community and no one will ever
know this happened because he's not he's
not a billionaire mark human he's just
owns a couple of car dealerships in a
small community that just got wiped out
by tornadoes and he's able to help right
he didn't have to call it government
doesn't have to call any cert he's able
to help
and the those stories go untold day
after day minute by minute all across
this country man
so the data
actually says
that when your
[ __ ] friend or family member says rich
people are evil
the data actually says that your friend
or relative is a [ __ ] but they're wrong
that's what the data says
it says that guy's a [ __ ] he's just
wrong
and he doesn't know what he's talking
about there's no first-hand knowledge he
has no data to back this up
because the actual data says that there
are no more evil people among rich
people than there are among poor people
turns out there's jerks that have money
and there's jerks that don't and there's
good people that have money and good
people that don't this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
logan and kelly are with us in
hattiesburg mississippi i see on my
screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you very much we're so excited to
be on the phone with you you too well
done how much debt have you paid off
we paid off 29 000 and eleven months
good for you and your range of income
during that time
we actually most people go up in income
we kind of went down because we moved
from indiana to mississippi so we went
from about 95 000 to now 70 000 as my
wife is just working part-time right now
very cool good what do you guys do for a
living
i'm a surgical technologist
and i'm a student pastor okay very good
and what kind of debt was your 29
thousand
the debt was all my college loans so
when kelly and i got married she was
completely debt free and i was not ah
okay all right so you're married up
i did i i married rich
it's a good thing
oh so tell us the story what happened
that put you guys on this journey 11
months ago plugging into ramsay
well i really what happened was when we
were preparing to get married she didn't
have any debt she kind of kicked my butt
into
into go mode and we had to
she said that we weren't going to have
any debt and i agreed with her i had
taken your class before we actually now
just taught financial piece and so
really it was just you know deciding
that we were going to make the decision
to become debt-free yeah we both were
working full-time jobs and doing side
gigs we did doordash
and logan officiated um just did
anything to attack the debt
i love it well done guys
that's proud of you yeah that's
fantastic so much what was the hardest
part as a married couple or as a dating
couple married newlyweds what was the
hardest part about this
the hardest part for me was you know
like i know a lot of males do is i kind
of felt i felt bad like i was bringing
in baggage to our marriage
and
as we were dating you know preparing to
get married i didn't want to be that
type of husband that was of course you
know no one wants to pull their spouse
down and i definitely didn't want to be
weighing my wife down with debt
to me i think the hardest part was just
not spending
when we get married i am the spender in
the relationship although i didn't have
debt um it was just hard for me to get
married and not be able to spend so but
it was so worth it now that we now that
we paid it off
wow the way to go guys
very cool all right so you're teaching
financial peace university you paid off
your debt you really did it and they ask
uh hey pastor how did you how did you
pay off twenty nine thousand dollars
what are you telling the secret is
we tell them the secret of of course is
to first pay
you know your ties that was a big we
never wavered on our ties
so that was first and then the second
was you just have to attack it do
anything focus on it yeah focus on it
and you know be intentional with your
money and ensure that
you're not just falling into the lies
that it can't be done because it's it's
a big dollar amount constantly i'd be
like okay how much that are we at like
it was just like a constant weekly thing
or daily thing you know we were just
constantly focusing on it
yeah wow way to go guys
very cool
it's a big deal that intentionality is
everything and there is something that
happens uh that god understands and we
don't that says when we give first
uh and we live a second it means we
trust him that something happens in our
spirit something happens in the universe
something happens in god's law
and we just see
things unfold to our benefit it's very
real so if you live like no one else
later you can live and give
like no one else but we're giving at
least a baseline of the tithe all the
way through and that's what our lessons
have always taught too so very good guys
very well done so you're going to be a
student pastor is that right a camp are
you a campus pastor
i'm actually i'm full time at a church
okay we're student pastors now so how
are you going to teach and educate
students on
their transition into college after
going through what you just went through
that's a great question one of the
things that i try and do as a student
pastor is provide a lot of practical
teaching
and then implement on implementation
skills on how they can do that
and you know i teach tithing and teach i
try and teach them now to save
and
to prepare for college or whatever their
next
route takes them because
life comes hard sometimes
and so one of the things that i
encourage is that and at the church is
that they take a financial piece
together before they get married
just working with our young adults
ministries so that they are ensure
are you teaching are you teaching high
school teams
i teach high schoolers yes how many high
schoolers in the group
we have about 80 students wow way to go
that's awesome man cool hey i want you
to recommend to them that they watch
borrowed future
uh the documentary that we did on the
epic failure of student loan debt i'm
going to send you a case of anthony
o'neal's book debt-free degree for your
high schoolers so they can go get
debt-free degrees
thank you so much we're also going to
give you a copy of baby steps
millionaires because that's the next
step or the next chapter in your story
as you move on and continue to be heroes
and what you're doing i'm so proud of
you guys well done
thank you both so much very cool very
cool all right count it down logan and
kelly hattiesburg mississippi
wow 29 000 paid off in 11 months it's
how they start their married life i love
it ding ding make a 95 down to now 70
with a move count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
yes sir
love it love it love it love it
well done
very well done good stuff
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five well the last
couple of years have been tough
they've been tough on relationships
they've been tough on people's mental
health
they've been tough on business and
economics they've been tough on finances
tough on marriages
you your spouse the kids have been
cooped up in quarantine
juggling online school work from home
maybe you've thrown in a job loss or a
job change and all that chaos is sucking
up
all of your bandwidth all your time your
energy you lost focus on the real issues
in your marriage
your money your intimacy your parenting
your communication the good news is with
the right tools these challenges can
bring you back
to your spouse and make you guys even
closer than before so rachel cruz and dr
john deloney to my right are back to
talk about
in a fan talk talk about how to do all
this in a fan favorite event the money
and marriage live stream
valentine's edition on friday february
the 11th rachel cruz and dr deloney
we'll walk you and your spouse through
the five keys to unlock your stronger
marriage in 2022 the marriage lie money
live stream is on sale right now starts
today only 20 bucks go to
ramseysolutions.com
events to learn more john this event has
always been a huge event yeah yeah it's
been a huge event and um it's it's it's
a
savior for couples because for 20 bucks
you can cuddle up on the couch you don't
have to go make reservations and get out
in the mess you can sit at home and
we really make it easy for you to have
some good conversations with your spouse
and to get closer and better connected
or to decide hey we got some healing we
got to do it's good we've got some work
to do that's right
yeah so it's a valentine's
valentine's day date night
dr john baloney
ramsey solutions.com
and uh again it's our uh annual money
and marriage live stream only 20 bucks
go over there and get signed up and make
that a date night on the 11th that's a
friday night and one thing is for sure
if delony and rachel cruz are there you
will be laughing there's gonna be some
chaos that's there will be some chaos
you will be laughing it will be fun and
funny it will not be accidental this is
gonna work you're gonna you're gonna
learn stuff but you're also going to
just have an entertaining evening these
guys are both world-class communicators
and both world-class with the content
and things they're going to bring to you
so the money and marriage live stream
on sale now only 20 dollars and for you
ramsey plus members uh if you're already
a member of ramsey plus you have free
access to this event part of your
membership if you're not a ramsey plus
member again it's only 20 bucks so uh
get the early bird rate
get your event passed today or jump on
ramsey plus go ahead and join and get
the financial beast university started
and you can get this valentine's day
money and marriage livestream
as part of the package
not a bad idea ramsay solutions dot com
slash events this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
dr trondalone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
landon and micah are with us in the
lobby of ramsey solutions on the debt
free stage to do a debt free screen hey
guys welcome hey gabe how's it going
good to have you guys i'm honored to
have you how much debt have you paid off
we paid about 132 thousand dollars whoa
how long did this take took about 11
months 11 months very impressive and
your range of income during that time
well we started about 40 000 and then we
went up to about 280 000
that's not a bad jump in a year somebody
got a raise
oh my gosh what do you guys do for a
living now so i work for a pro-life
organization as a continuing care
coordinator
and i'm a turf and pest control
technician but i also started a car
small carpentry business during that
time which is where the 280 came from
okay that turned into not so small yeah
yeah wow well everybody's going crazy in
construction it's just wild out there
absolutely you caught a wave man what's
your carpentry skill uh pretty much
anything you need but mostly just
furniture and stuff like that
oh you're building fine fine
okay wow very neat yeah that's where
some money can come in excellent
excellent look at you guys
very fun so what started this journey 11
months ago
uh so i mean
i wish we had like this huge climactic
moment where like we had this major turn
around um but it really just didn't
happen that way um i was homeschooled my
whole life and um my mom basically
crammed your program down our throats
part of our schooling
for our entire homeschooling lives and
so you know it's really just always been
in my head you don't get a credit card
you don't get a car payment you don't
get any kind of debt and so you know
what i mean i just grew up never having
any kind of debt
um and so we did what was 132 000 that
was our oh you paid your house
people yep for sure
you gotta lead with that one you have a
how old are y'all uh i'm 24. i'm 25.
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
280 000 a year 24 and 25 years old with
a paid for house what's this house worth
about 185 way to go mom cramming it down
your throat yeah oh my gosh you're on
your way to be millionaires in no time
you're amazing wow
very cool so you got how long have you
been married uh about just over 30 yeah
three and a half years okay three and a
half years and you bought a house and
then 11 months ago you said
paint it off yeah well we actually found
out that we were having our first baby
and so we basically said to ourselves uh
you know what would life be like if we
could have our first kid not have a
payment in the world
and so we basically just kind of said
challenge accepted and said that we
wanted to be the last twistdales
shoot why am i crying
because you broke your family tree man
we basically said that we wanted to be
the last twistdales ever in doubt in
this in this part of the family tree
that was ever a slave to the lender yeah
i love that why am i crying it's awesome
because it's amazing because we promised
myself i wasn't going to do something
when you do something that breaks the
mold yeah yeah your body feels it man
that's crazy is incredible yeah how many
couples get pregnant and say
how how how much can we doll up this
this one pound humans or the 10-pound
humans room right and let's add all
these trinkets and stuff and you guys
said what if we set this kid up for a
life that's not gonna know the stress
the anxiety the the rattling that goes
on you guys did it
you did it man wow
you should literally change your family
tree and you're 24 and 25. you're
amazing
you're amazing and so impressive what
was the hardest part about this journey
i think for me it was the nights and
days that we didn't really see each
other because of work
yeah i mean it was it was 18 hours a day
six days a week uh grinding all the time
i think the hardest part definitely i
mean other than that had to be just the
relentless physical labor um you know
just to i mean you know till 5am 48
hours straight sometimes 60 hours
straight with no sleep sometimes
i mean i would drive all the way to
nashville to deliver some pieces drive
to little rock to deliver some pieces um
just nonstop all the time grinding yeah
wow but ding you brought in some serious
cash yep yep and you can do anything for
a short period of time yeah you work
like no one else now you can work like
no one that's exactly right right now
you'll get the furniture when i'm
through with it that's right
after i get done holding my little baby
for as long as i want yeah that's right
yeah and you guys that's so cool
very cool well obviously hard work is a
big part of your equation and
i love your mom homeschooling cramming
this stuff down your throat and i hear
he stands as a young dad yeah not a
payment yeah we would literally be on
the way to disney world on vacations and
we would be watching the videos on the
little small tvs that would be used to
be in the vans and stuff we'd be
watching the videos on the way to disney
world having to take notes and
everything little kids going to watch
dave ramsey oh god help them
so there's counseling needed for that oh
man in the van in the van i mean other
kids watching little mermaid he gets to
watch favorites
oh man wow it's pretty amazing
how
you all have friends who've been married
for a few years too
when you hear the struggles they're
going through and the how their marriage
is going and how it's not
how would you stack your marriage up
against theirs
and and i know you shouldn't compare
these kind of things i'm asking you to
compare these well we've actually been
having ever since we did this we've had
a lot of conversations with people our
age um just because they want to know
how we did it and stuff like that and
just here in situations that people our
age are in
or um i may voluntarily put themselves
in um it's pretty wild
you know the stories we've heard because
you know growing up like we did you know
i just thought that every i mean i
thought everybody paid cash for cars i
mean why would you not pay cash for a
car um you know so it was weird um
hearing these different stories of
different situations um and i was even
reading baby steps millionaires
yesterday and reading the data in the
back of the book and i was telling her i
was like the average millionaire on here
paid their house off at like 50. i think
we're all right
you are more than all right my friend
yeah
you are more than all right my friend
you'll be there you're gonna be there by
the way you're gonna be the guy that
your kid calls and says i got a buddy
who really needs some help and you can
say
tell them to meet me at coffee and we'll
be able to bless them in a way that they
don't even know what's coming right for
sure you oh my gosh man that's
incredible very neat how inspirational
man so uh what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
i would say to find people that will
encourage you throughout the whole
process and be there for you i would say
i i think it's the most obvious but the
most difficult thing of the entire thing
and that's never giving up
um you know because i think everybody
goes through storms from all the
hundreds of debt-free screams that i've
lessened somebody went through storms in
the middle of it we did we had one month
where her car locked up the engine
locked up the heat and air went out and
she had medical bills from the pregnancy
it's about 14 000 a month in bills wow
um stuff like that makes you want to
give up i'm i'll tell you what
but instead of giving up in the middle
of a storm we would just ask ourselves
what can we accomplish in the rain
and so i think the key would be to never
give up
great song great song title i like it
wow what can we accomplish in the ring
good stuff man
if you listen to this show for five
minutes you know that i'm rarely
speechless and i don't the words aren't
coming
i don't have i just hope people are
listening to this you got a young couple
who decided we're going to get on the
same page we're going to have a singular
goal
i'm not going to take tired for an
answer for a short period of time this
isn't sustainable but i'm going to do it
for a short period of time for that
little bundle of joy i'm looking at
right over there we're going to go
through storms we're going to figure out
who we are in the midst of madness we're
going to keep going keep going never
give up never give up
and you changed it all man
michael you said you the support was
everything who are your cheerleaders
that are here with you
it's definitely our family um they have
been there through it all and
um yeah who all's with you this is my
parents my siblings her parents her
grandparents um i think that's it oh and
my brother-in-law and nephews oh wow
okay so is that your grandparents i met
from south america yes all right very
cool very cool wow wow we're so honored
you guys what a neat story do you want
to hold your little ones yeah
yeah i'll bring him in there i got them
headphones what's his name
lucas lucas way to go lucas all right
well hopefully you won't see a new new
baby
oh wow
11 months they did it house and
everything 132 000
paid off 24 and 25 years old with a
paid-for house making 40 to 280. i ain't
saying tired i'm getting it done
landon and micah from memphis count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
lucas never moved never flinched
so cool yes
wow
powerful
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today welcome to the ramsey show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five amy is in dallas
texas hi amy welcome to the ramsey show
hi mr ramsey how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um i got two quick questions so first
one is
does it really matter if i invest in
real estate or mutual funds because i'd
really rather not be a landlord
you do not have to invest in real estate
okay so it's pretty much the same okay
so the second question is um should i
roll over my traditional 401k to a roth
401k
basically i already asked my company if
they would do it and they said no but
should i push that or is that like
probably something that they just don't
offer
uh they probably don't have a choice but
no you should not do it unless you're on
baby step seven and have extra money i
am on baby step seven for sure and i
have i can i can take the
300 in my husband so 700 total thousand
dollars
yes sir okay so your tax bill is
three hundred thousand dollars
yeah i don't know if i i could probably
piecemeal that you know each year so
basically a little more i'm 32
net worth of around two million
maybe step seven
houses paid for obviously baby step 7.
yeah i would roll it i would roll it to
a roth and i'd certainly not put
anything in the roth
in anything in any traditional going
forward your company offers a roth but
they will not they're not offering the
option for you to roll your traditional
portion into the roth portion
correct and i would yeah i mean i think
you can push
that's that's technically allowable
and i'm not positive that they
technically can deny you doing that
okay once they offer once they offer a
roth if they don't offer a raw 401k then
they could obviously say well we don't
have that available but if they've got
it available to do
see i've got a roth here let me give you
an example how i know that okay i've got
a roth here at the company
at my company and the matching portion
has to be traditional
but i every year roll the matching
portion after the match is given to me
into the roth portion and i pay the
taxes on it
right i heard that so i was like huh
interesting idea yeah so you can do that
if you want to do that now uh your
company his company both if they both
have roth ir roth 401ks available
i i'm not i can't tell you for sure that
they have to
uh we know technically they can because
they it's available to you um and i'm
not sure they technically by regulation
can deny you doing that i think they
just don't want to screw with it so walk
me through the math on that dave so if
i've got 700 grand
and i and traditionally i roll it to a
roth i got to pay taxes on that you got
to pay taxes so that's going to cut it
in half it's going to you're not going
to take the money out
you're going to take 300k from somewhere
else
and pay the taxes okay and then that
700k is going to grow tax-free from now
on so mathematically
it's as if you put another 300 into your
traditional
because you're going to pay taxes on it
if you had put the 300 you paid in taxes
into this one right it would have grown
enough the 700 now a million would have
grown to enough to pay the taxes on the
traditional okay so it's it has the same
mathematical effect as an additional 300
000 being invested into your
uh into your 401
because you're paying the taxes on the
side wow you don't do that stuff till
you get to baby step seven though okay
because you need that other money if you
when you're you use that 300k if you had
mortgage you wouldn't use that 300k if
you had other debt okay yeah so you're a
baby step seven though and she's two
million dollar net worth at 32 years old
dink ding another baby steps millionaire
they're everywhere out there they're
everywhere christine is with us
christine's in st louis hi christine how
are you
i am very thankful to be talking with
both of you today thank you for taking
my call certainly how can we help
well i'm living a country song so i'm
hoping you might be able to give me some
ethics advice um
i was a travel nurse until i had a
stroke last year and it knocked me flat
thank you i am at this point i'm
physically able to work um a half day
about two to three days a week so praise
god and healing but all the ways to go
um
while i was travel nursing i held my
tithe aside in a separate account
because i didn't have a home church
and
in the last
number of months i've just had
back-to-back to back-to-back-to-back
emergencies so i've used up my
six-month emergency fund and i've used
up my emergency fund emergency fund
and um now i have property taxes and a
640 prescription due next month and i'm
wondering about the ethics of
dipping into that
tithe account as a second
emergency fund in this situation okay
all right you have children
i do not i am single and married okay
cool all right do you have a good
relationship with your dad
uh yes they have already helped um
i wasn't asking i wasn't asking for that
reason i was asking for another reason
so okay okay here's the thing
god is our heavenly father
scripture is very clear on this
he's absolutely crazy about you
just like your dad is
he thinks you're amazing
and he says to you my daughter
the best way to live your life
is to be generous
generous people prosper generous people
have better lives than selfish people
a baseline for the generosity is a tenth
of your income going into your local
church
now let's get this straight
god
owns the cattle on a thousand hills
he owns the hills
he does not need your money
and if his bride the church needs your
money
then they are confused
because their source is not you their
source is god
so um the ba the tithe is to get you
into a rhythm
of giving because giving is good for you
it's not an ethics
or a moral question
that makes you bad
it's like god says if you eat donuts
by the by the box you will get fat my
daughter
don't eat them that's what he said to me
by the way
dave don't eat donuts you will get fat
because when i can eat every donut in a
50 mile radius but is god mad at me if i
eat a donut no he just said your best
life is if you're generous
and eat healthy and exercise every day
that's your best life i know that
and um
my my dad in heaven that loves me
says that and he loves you and he's not
worried about the tithe
so if you need to use this money to eat
you're gonna be just fine don't ever
give
out of a sense of duty
or out of a sense of legalism or rules
give because it's the best way to live
your life
right now the best way to live your life
is pay your prescription bills to live
and to live your life and you'll get
back to giving soon enough
okay so lots of grace
on the tithe i'm a tither i believe in
tithing
i come from a trade i got i got saved i
met god in a tradition that teaches
tithing i i teach it i do believe it but
with absolutely zero legalism lots and
lots of grace on it
okay that gives me a lot of a lot more
comfort what would your dad say if he
gave you
a hundred thousand dollars and he said
oh you need to give ten thousand dollars
of this to the church and then you got
your back up against the wall like you
do right now would your dad be mad at
you if you use that ten thousand dollars
your dad loves you he would not be mad
at you
thank you that's why i appreciate you
walking me through that that's why i
asked you about your dad's relationship
right there
because this is your heavenly father
it's the same thing
and if i can see a healthy heaven
earthly father smiling how much more so
our father in heaven
amen
you're gonna be okay i'm sorry you've
been through this yeah
well god's carried me this far and
now i understand the grace a little
better that'll carry me through the next
cup yeah and you you'll get back to
giving you're going to end up giving a
whole lot more than this amount of money
through the course of your life
above the tithe
you'll make up the ground just because
of who you are aren't you
thank you you're a nurse
yeah we love you darling thank you for
calling sorry you had this year it's a
tough year
amazing
dr john dolone good show thank you my
man good hour good hour good job to the
folks in the booth james and ben and
kelly well done i am dave ramsey your
host and we'll be back with you
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host open phones at
triple eight eight two five five
two two five better special treat for
you guys this half hour we've uh got one
of our good friends on here who has a
new best-selling book out called hero on
a mission
donald miller is with us donald has
written several best-selling books
starting all the way back to blue like
jazz and all the way up through business
made simple was the book before this one
and of course story brand probably my
favorite uh business book by donald
miller and uh this new one has done very
very well we want to talk about it today
welcome back my brother it's really
great to be here good to have you good
to have you hero on a mission
a path to a meaningful life
it's really good
so uh tell us about this now i i when i
saw the title i know story brand yeah
and i thought okay i want to be a hero
right right in this classic story arc
right and uh you talk a lot about
storytelling in the other books that
you've written and the the power of
story and marketing is what storybrand
is about
but um
i i immediately thought i kind of know
where he's going with this hero he's got
a hero in the story right and we're
going to put him on a mission this is
good yeah you know i wrote the book
really as an antidote to victim
mentality oh
that's really what the book was because
or what it is because uh you know i mean
you know as well as i do there just
seems to be more and more victim
mentality creeping into our culture
and you know if it's creeping into our
culture it's creeping into us
and i lost 10 years of my life because i
saw myself as a victim in the story this
was in my 20s
and was driven by moods you know
thought that
you know other people had stuff that i
couldn't get there's something wrong
with me and some of that you know it
comes from growing up hard and those
kinds of things but when i studied story
in order to write the books i was
writing i started seeing these
characters the victim the villain the
hero the guide the four major characters
and stories and i realized these
characters are existing stories not
because they're out there like that
guy's a victim that guy's a villain that
guys they exist in stories because all
four characters actually exist in us
you know when i'm stuck in traffic i i
surface villain energy so fast
you can be the villain and then in the
face of a reese's peanut butter cup i
surface victim energy real quick and you
know so on so of course we're making
light of this but um what i realized was
the more i identify as a victim the
worse my life gets
and
in other words the victim thinks that
they're doomed a victim thinks that they
are uniquely
challenged in life and nobody else has
hard days but they do
and truly a lot of us actually could
identify as victims because very hard
things have happened to you sometimes we
are saying because an actual victim you
know henry cloud our friend defines vic
a victim as somebody who has no way out
yeah and often though we really do and
so the more i see myself as saying i
could choose to see myself as a victim
well there's a there's a hero
you know you're there's a difference
between becoming offended right and
living your life offended that's right
there's a difference between being a
victim of something i've been the victim
of something i've been the victim of a
guy t-boning my car right in the side i
did didn't anything wrong i was the
victim of that right but then i don't
choose to identify
i was victimized there for a moment when
he popped this out of my car you know
yeah but i'm not a permanent victim
uh i just was well here's the other
thing that happens though if you watch
stories heroes are always getting their
cars t-boned and falling off buildings
and somebody's hero always has a moment
where they're the victims
any movie and the hero is not having a
good time yeah there's a moment that
they're being victimized that's right
but they don't become a victim they
don't self-identify that way and if you
watch a movie powerful here's what
happens to a victim at the end
they're rescued they sit them on the
back of the ambulance put a blanket
around them and then the camera goes
over and follows the hero
because the story is not about the
victim the victim doesn't transform they
don't get rewarded they don't end up
blessed at the end of the day they're a
bit part in the story that does two
things makes the hero look good and
makes the villain look bad
and so when we choose to identify as a
victim in our own stories dave nothing
good happens to us
it's very tempting though because we
might attract resources we get other
people to do our work we attract some
sympathy there there are coping
mechanisms about being a victim that
sometimes worked it's one of the reasons
i say look if you're playing the victim
or if you identify yourself don't
actually be too judgmental on yourself
because when you do that you actually
turn into the villain
and you can have a villain inside you
that's judging the victim i say ignore
them all
start living like a hero on a mission
start having some sort of ambition
face challenges as they come
transform into a better version of
yourself accomplish something you didn't
think you could accomplish and when
you're done you won't just have some
rewards you will have a new identity and
the more we spend
time playing the hero the less we're
tempted by victim and villain mentality
and the better your life goes
i always think about just roar you know
it's like you just throw back your head
and roar you know
we were in africa you know in the middle
of the night eight miles away you can
hear a lion roaring the decibels are
unbelievable but there's this that's
what the the hero does they're not
necessarily a predator i don't mean that
but they nobody can hear the hero
we're going to do this you know yeah
they rise up throw their shoulders
forward and lean into it you know yeah
they don't shrink back and uh try to
find excuses and and i'm on a mission
yeah i got knocked down but that's not
my identity i'm not the victim and uh
yeah somebody said i'm a villain and i
like what caroline leifer i wrote this
down the other day
dr caroline leaf says sometimes you will
be the villain in someone else's
narrative and you need to be okay with
this but you're not responsible for
their version well they see you as a
villain and sometimes
people who call other somebody else a
villain
are actually the villains themselves
because what they've done is they've
diminished this person they've labeled
them for one thing
that they did they didn't have a nuanced
understanding and when you go that
person say i don't actually think that
person's a villain
they can't let go of the fact that
you're a villain because the villain
makes them self-righteous right so they
have to wrongly accuse somebody of being
a villain or to feel good themselves
cancer culture that's exactly it i
literally just shared this on my podcast
this is my problem with cancel culture
is that you are actually pretending to
be a victim
but but you're actually acting like a
villain canceling somebody else and
diminishing them and you know and
sometimes people need to be reprimanded
sometimes people need to publicly
apologize i'm not saying you know
there's something but to actually cancel
somebody to actually say you should not
have a voice in this society you should
be quiet you should go away in fact you
should you should be marginalized from
the community and starve to death is
what they're saying yeah that's a
villainous thing to say about any about
pretty much anybody and so you know why
you got your
this book enlightens us i think
hopefully the goal of the book is to
make us self-aware
so that we realize oh i'm playing the
victim right now and this is not going
to go anywhere good or i'm playing the
villain this is not going to go anywhere
good it's always about somebody else
when you're the victim of the villain
but well they have agency over you yeah
the victim gives agency to somebody
outside themselves who controls their
moods their life and where things go the
hero accepts their own agency to change
things good stuff more on this we want
to hear the rest of this this is great
it's just so empowering throw back your
head and roar it's hero
on a mission
get it where all great books are sold it
came out last week
donald miller is the author with me for
one more segment be sure you stay tuned
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much pure
talk gives you the same great 5g
coverage on the same 5g network as one
of the big guys for half the cost the
average family saves over
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
the book is hero on a mission
by donald miller a path to a meaningful
life
you want to get the book on amazon or
anywhere great books are sold anything
donald writes i can promise you is worth
reading he said multiple bestsellers
he's a world-class author and a good
friend we hang out together our wives
like each other
and uh we i've done donald spoken at our
events and um pretty incredible okay
now i'm not sure i want to do this one
start your day
by reading your eulogy yeah
i get it
i understand
but that's a little more i mean that's
just
i feel like a victim right now yeah yeah
i do it almost every day i uh four out
of seven days okay i i this morning i
read my eulogy okay now this is a old
practice stephen covey talked about in
seven habits he got he got it from
somebody else it is a little morbid to
be brutally honest with you but
what it does for me is it it helps me
start with the end in mind when you
write a story
normally screenwriters write with the
climactic scene you know the man and the
woman get married and then they reverse
engineer a story that gets them there
and one of the things that i do is i
read my eulogy there are three major
stories in my life i've got about 30
years left that's it
in 30 years i want to tell a great story
as a family i want to tell a great story
in my career and i want to tell a great
story as a civilian in the united states
of america i want to contribute three
really good stories to those areas of my
life now because i read my eulogy
several things happen
one is
a sense of urgency develops i've got 30
years you you don't have time to mess
around you got to get something on this
i call it putting something on the plot
the other thing is reading my eulogy
every day really helps me say no
because if somebody comes to me and says
don you know we'd love for you to you
know try your your your
your hat throw your hat as a sitcom and
be an actor whatever i don't have time
for that i have three stories left
there's no time to take amazing
opportunity i have three stories left if
i want to have an impact in this world
and it really helps me understand you
know dave you know our family well
enough no we just had a baby seven
months ago emma line
if i make it to 80
emmeline's got me for 30 years
that's it
now i don't get any of that time back so
if i'm not constantly aware that this is
a limited time experience here
i might be tempted to you know get too
lost in my work to spend time with my
daughter
so that every morning reading my eulogy
really helps set my story up for success
and let me define success a meaningful
experience
to wake up every day
and have a meaningful experience with
life it's not happy all the time there's
not always joy sometimes there's
sacrificed sometimes they're suffering
but it's always meaningful and by
meaningful what i really mean is i'm
interested in my own story
my story is interesting enough that i'm
not bored by it i'm not restless i think
a lot of people i'm not stuck i'm not
stuck a lot of people hit midlife and
they feel as though they're sitting in
the theater of their mind watching an
empty screen because the movie about
their childhood is over the movie about
their college experience is over the
movie about falling in love and starting
a family is over and they never took
personal agency to start another story
yeah so what happens is a peripheral in
their peripheral vision a blind and a
convertible goes by and they have what
we then call a midlife crisis that's
exactly it and i think what midlife
crisis actually is is the failure to to
define a narrative that you can live
within right so the failure to have a
story laid out sigmund freud went around
the world and said
look the dominant motivation of mankind
is to pursue pleasure
there was a guy named victor frankl who
i talk about in this book created
something called logotherapy he said
sigmund freud is wrong he said the
dominant desire of mankind is not
pleasure it's meaning and when he cannot
find meaning he distracts himself with
pleasure
if you don't define a story for your
life and live into it
you're going to go numb that pain
somewhere and you're going to get in all
sorts of stupid decisions boredom
equals purchasing stuff you don't need
three things you should need that's
right and just keep adding to it it's
hedonism it leads you into hedonism
that's exactly that's uh and it and it
is and the irony of hedonism is it
doesn't work right
it doesn't bring you joy no it doesn't
fulfill you it distracts you from the
fact that you're not fulfilled
temporarily powerful yeah powerful okay
the difference between someone who's
stuck and someone found a path forward
they've defined a narrative for
themselves same what we're talking about
exactly so if if there's you know
there's basically three things i really
want in life right now one is a
family and we have a story that we're
living as a family it involves a little
retreat center that you've been to
the other one is my company and you know
we're trying to
right now we're trying to move into the
college system teach these young kids
how to be entrepreneurs that's that's a
big story for me uh and the third is a
political thing that i want to get
started about 10 years from now i really
haven't put much on it right now
those three story questions will don be
able to be a great dad and a loving
husband as he builds this sort of
retreat center here in nashville will
don be able to educate the next
generation of entrepreneurs uh to to
grow up and start companies and will dom
be able to to do this thing in the
political sphere those are the three
story questions in my life
and i ask myself those questions every
day what that does is it gives me
narrative traction and so to the
listener i say is there a story question
in your life that compels you forward if
there isn't let me tell you who's
dictating your story corporations
credit card companies marketing agencies
talk show hosts
hating on the government
there are people who are financially
incentivized to get you to step into the
story they're creating but what about
your story have you created a story for
yourself do you have agency because i
think it's a much better deal if you
create the story for yourself and live
into it so i think that's what happens
when uh
someone
says okay i'm overwhelmed with debt i'm
stuck
and
when we put out there hey maybe your
story is you change your family tree yep
absolutely and not only that but this
but you know this is a story within your
life that we would call it a subplot
yeah so here's the story money's not the
whole thing there's your economic
subplot your spiritual subplot there's
your love story whatever wherever you're
stuck if you can rise above it and have
some sense of nobility then you become
the hero instead of the victim and i
would actually argue i think victor
frank would argue that when you decide
hey i'm 43 000 in debt we're gonna get
out of this debt it's gonna take us
about three years and you live into that
you focus you overcome challenges you
know you don't eat out you do all this
kind of stuff
you're actually entering into what
viktor frankl calls logotherapy and that
is a therapy of meaning and a therapy of
meaning happens when you have three
things one is an objective
something to try to do something to try
to build
second is community so if you're doing
with this as a family your whole
community's bought and it's actually
bringing you closer to tackle this
ambition together and the third is a
redemptive or optimistic perspective on
suffering
victor frank would say suffering is
inevitable you're not going to get
around it but you can look at suffering
and say yeah this is hard this is
painful and also it's building character
yeah and also it's building discipline
and also it's giving me
empathy if you can have that sort of and
also view on suffering it actually
creates a deep sense of meaning and i
discovered this about 10 or 12 years ago
when i read viktor frankl's book and
began to apply to my life and you know
by the way the book is called in search
of a band search for meaning there's
another book called yes to life that's
shorter and i think to some degree
better but you know
i i read that book and applied that to
my life and have tried to spend the last
10 years writing it in a simplified
language because he uses such clinical
language so here on a mission is my
attempt to explain what victor frank was
talking about
you know for the last 10 years there
have been tragedy has struck our
community there's been sad days there's
been times when i've been angry there's
there but there's not been a single day
when i haven't woken up interested in my
own story
and when you wake up and you're not
interested in your own story viktor
frankl calls it the existential vacuum
it's it's what i call a narrative void
you have no story
that you're living you are a character
wandering around without a plot without
a script without a reason and it's going
to drive you crazy well the stress of
the quarantines
and the stress surfaced all endemic uh
well it it people thought they were on a
mission and then it was taken away from
them yeah
and some people discovered what was
taken away from them was actually a
distraction from meaning yeah and they
realized i didn't like my life before
so now we've got a huge number of people
changing jobs changing jobs and
transitioning and writing a new story
for their lives that's it good stuff the
book is hero on a mission by donald
miller he's a new york times
best-selling author a path to a
meaningful life thanks for stopping by
my friend thanks dave good to have you
be sure and check out anything donald
wright's it's uh definitely worth the
time this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's bethel betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage dan and lindsay are with
us hey guys how are you hey dave yeah
better than we deserve amen welcome
where do you guys live
spring valley wisconsin we're about an
hour east of the twin cities in
minnesota okay welcome around eau claire
then yeah okay you got it good good
welcome welcome good to have you thank
you how much debt are you paid off
four hundred twenty one thousand five
hundred and eighteen dollars and nine
cents wow
how long did this take
three three years in one month yeah wow
this is a lot all right and your range
of income during that time and we
started the year before we got to know
you were about 150 000 last couple years
we've been at about 220.
man you've been honking it what do you
all do for a living we own a small
business we're a custom hardwood
flooring contractor oh
okay nice times nice time yes it's been
good good times we need some more
competition so
[Laughter]
or not
so
we can't help them all dave what what
well that's true that's true you need
some help in the marketplace yeah the uh
so the 422 000 what kind of that was
this
it was business our house we had a car
yeah you paid off your home yes sure did
everything you're 100 done we don't know
anybody anything i'm looking at weird
people
[Applause]
way to go you guys very amazing thank
you so proud of you very well done how
old are you two 34 and he's 33 yeah and
you're a hundred percent debt-free
business is making serious bank has no
debt on it
house is paid off what's the house worth
about 370.
[Laughter]
i love it
[Laughter]
way to go you guys pretty amazing well
done
okay so um you're making 150 was that in
the business yeah that was the first
year um we had purchased the business
that i worked in okay and then it just
took off right not only you you applied
yourself to it but also the weirdness of
coven made you high in demand yes
everyone's working from home and looking
at their floors thinking we need to do
something about it
a lot of buildings were empty so gym
floors weren't being used commercial
buildings weren't being used so we got
hit hard with the commercial stuff right
away yeah oh yeah dropped off okay all
right well that makes sense
oh wow so how did you get how how long
you guys have been married 13 years okay
so three years ago 10 years into the
marriage
approximately
you decide game on
before covet hits
we're gonna we're gonna take all this
we're gonna get rid of this dad tell me
the story how did you get connected to
ramsey what'd you do well
it kind of started we we bought the
business 2017
um
and then about a year into it and before
we bought the business we didn't have
any debt except our house
and we kind of always have been frugal
kind of always been but that's not much
of a plan though it was just a tight wad
that's about all it was
so we bought the business and that
consisted of four different lenders
um
and then of course you buy a business so
you buy a car
that's just next in the steps oh of
course yeah right so what are you into
it we look totally logical right
looked up and went from
almost no debt towing everybody right
debt is heavy and it was really the
emotional aspect that got it we started
looking at not only our employees but
their families as well and just feeling
responsible for that
we weren't really struggling with money
we were able to pay the bills and that
obviously means you can afford it right
well the emotional aspect is really what
got us and so i i still remember the
actual job site that i was working on
when i started searching for books or
podcasts something that was in that
financial realm
i found your total money makeover book
on audible listen to the sample and then
i listened to the rest of the book
came home told her said hey
we're going to listen to this guy and
she kind of looked at me
um because apparently she told me about
you before about like yeah nine years
before
yeah
no
putting the kids in bed that night i
walked up the stairs and sure enough we
have a bookshelf from the top of the
stairs there you are your book was
sitting laughing at me
yeah
so
it yeah it was really just waiting for
me i guess
why when the student is ready yeah
that's right wow you guys are amazing
so okay so now we're in agreement both
of you say we've got this weight we have
this healthy disgust there's not really
a crisis just the weight of it and said
i don't like living like this i feel
like i'm out of control i feel like i
can't
you know be responsible to my team and
make sure they're okay
and then boom you start getting some
information lights you up you get on the
same page and you go right that's right
wow
really started looking then i mean
paying off the mortgage was something
that was going to take us 30 years
because that's what we thought it took
then we started looking at the numbers
how much we were able to pay off this
debt uh the business side is really what
pushed us i part of that was owning or
owing my old boss money it was partially
on our finance so i wanted to get out
from under there
[Music]
he wasn't mad about your playing anymore
either no no he wasn't
um
so we started looking at the numbers and
how how fast that was going and then we
were able to see man we can have our
house paid off yeah we could just keep
going how much of the 422 was the
business how much it was it's about half
a half okay yeah
so about 210 each yeah okay all right
wow very cool good for you guys thank
you thank you you're 33 years old
you're making that free 300 200 000 a
year and you have zero debt house or
anything yes sir how does that feel it's
amazing yeah incredible we had to get
the house taken care of quick because
winter was coming and you can't walk in
the yard in wisconsin in wintertime yeah
we wanted to be able to appreciate our
own lawn that's all we got to do it have
to walk through the backyard barefoot
the grass feels different that's a
ramsey ramsay saying for you newbies out
there
and yeah doing that in in the winter in
wisconsin would be less than profitable
yeah i'm with you on that i could like
frostbite or something
wow way to go you guys all right now
this is a pretty impressive move here i
mean you this is a power move three
years in one month you pay off 422
thousand you're living on nothing yeah
you aren't generating you are not buying
a bunch of equipment in the business
you're you're just running the business
and you're running it wide open and
you're working like a crazy man how many
hours a week week were you working uh i
mean
minimum of 12 hours a day usually 15 to
18 hours um a lot of what we do we do a
lot of staircase work and so i was able
to come home from our on-site work
and sand and refinish their treads and
risers and in our wood shop so come home
from work eat supper go back to work out
in the wood shop and
um yeah 18 hours a day was a thing so
for two three years you did this right
just like a wild man so now you can dial
it back yeah yeah yeah yeah you do need
a dolly back yes
yeah yeah yeah you will live like no one
else so later you can live like no one
else
yeah you pay a price to win and you did
and now we're gonna live and give like
no one else you guys are incredible so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is
i'd say find that contentment in the
journey if you're just sitting there
looking at things like i don't have this
and i don't have that you're not gonna
succeed but if you can find that content
contentness inside that journey you're
going to
go so far
i kind of have three things first off
put god first in everything you do and
that's not just saying that's
that's a real life for real yeah yeah
walk of life and then for all you guys
up there go find yourself a virtuous
woman
and yeah i'm thinking you're working 18
hour days but she's got three kids yeah
she's working 20 hours a day part of
that was homeschooled through cohen
doing all the books in the business whoa
yeah yeah she put in as many hours as
you did every morning yeah
yeah and and i noticed she didn't win a
roller eyes when you're describing it
either no yeah that's a big deal i'm
with you on this yeah all right and then
i'd have to say effort um you know
there's really nothing special about us
neither one of us have college degrees
you know we're what this society would
call undereducated
but understanding the power and the
value in effort
that's really you know get up get it
done and let me tell you when you got
dave ramsey jocko willink and micro in
your ear while you're at work or you
just grab another cup of coffee get back
to work those three guys will give you
no mercy on hard work none of us none of
the three of us will let you up yeah
let's tell you maybe we can sleep next
week be like the three stooges right
there man i'm telling you wow
and the good news is those are both
really good guys i'm honored to be in
their company so
good stuff very good stuff cool all
right you brought the kiddos what are
their names and ages let's get them into
the shot and we're going to give you a
copy of the baby steps millionaires how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too because that's
the next chapter in your story to be
millionaires you are right on your way
what are their names and ages
shaden is 11. weston is eight and everly
is two perfect 422 thousand dollars paid
off three years in one month making 150
to 220 18 hour days count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
[Applause]
what a great family
oh now they'll be able to do anything
they want they're only 33.
this is the ram z shaft
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
every january we get hundreds of calls
from people who are ready to start fresh
and take control of their money
without a plan most of them never make
progress
so they quit
maybe you've been there too
but 2022 can be different this year you
can win with money
by following a plan that's worked for
millions of people
we teach it to you in financial peace
university
you'll learn a step by step how to save
money how to get out of debt and how to
build wealth
become a baby steps millionaire and give
generously
you can go through the class with other
people or you can watch it online
either way financial peace university is
available through a ramsey plus
membership
this year you can take control of your
money for good start fpu
for free by visiting for a free trial
at ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash fpu our question of the day comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your window blinds
for free this is a great company you get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more
always use the magic word the promo code
ramsey
blinds.com today's question is from
jamie in texas dave i just blew most of
my 1 000 work bonus on my online
gambling addiction
i know i did the dumbest thing possible
and i need help with this addiction
i've talked to my family about it and
they're extremely supportive
but now i've started lying about it and
i feel so much guilt
please help me so i can refocus and stop
gambling
my hard-earned money away
jamie um
you have gotten caught up in
the one of the two largest and fastest
growing addictions in america today
um
number one addiction in america today is
online porn number two is gambling and
it includes sports betting and sports
betting right now in the height of
football season is completely over the
top and out of control if i see caesar
one more time i'm gonna shoot something
i'm so sick of these commercials but
they're making so much money off you
people you think those commercials are
free
you know why that commercial runs on
every break people because they make so
much money off you
so jamie i'm sorry i'm sorry you're
struggling with this it's a very harsh
thing
the great news is you have recognized
where you are
that you are addicted
and i'm running into a lot of young men
in their 20s and early 30s who are
losing everything to gambling addiction
right now
uh personal friends
lost jobs marriages
you know my kids personal friends it's
it's it's wild and it's really sad
so your right to be concerned
and scared
and self-aware about the guilt and the
regret
and the sense of no control
so what would i do if i found myself in
that situation
i'm i'm not sitting here with dr john
deloney at this moment so i can't have
him chime in as a professional counselor
but i can tell you as a guy who's been
around addicts my whole life working
with them because a hundred percent of
addicts eventually end up broke
so we get to talk to them all the time
you have got to get
some people
and some processes
in your corner to help you
and so if i woke up in your shoes
i would go talk to my pastor and and
start having a weekly lunch with him
i would get plugged into gamblers
anonymous immediately
i would also call
a therapist a counselor
and start sitting down with a counselor
daily weekly whatever it takes
even if it costs some money because this
gambling thing is going to cost you
everything if you don't break it
it is evil and it is vicious
it is merciless what it will do to you
it will beat the snot out of you and
leave you on the side of the road for
dead dude
and so you have got to be very afraid of
the power of this over you
so afraid that you take drastic changes
and you don't worry about embarrassment
you tell everybody i'm addicted help me
i'm addicted to this help me get out of
it help me heal this addiction help me
get away from it get in gamblers
anonymous get with a one-on-one
counselor get with your pastor and
lastly get a group of friends in your
life who will bust you
not the ones who you know are saying
it's okay
and your family it sounds like when you
say they're supportive it sounds like
they've been soft
if you were in my life i would love you
so much that you would feel it
i'm gonna be all up in your stuff
because i love you so much that that's
what it's going to take
a a pat on the back
and a yay raw doesn't help when you're
an addict
it takes more force
than that to move people out of an
addictive behavior
and to move them into the help that they
need to break an addictive behavior
and so it is not a it is not an act of
love to be soft
on an addict
it is quite the opposite it's borderline
enabling if not full-on enabling
so
jamie i appreciate that your family is
extremely supportive but what extremely
supportive should be is making you
highly uncomfortable
not comfortable
and the way you're saying that i kind of
think they're going oh poor jamie
you know i'm gonna bust jamie's what i'm
gonna do because i love him
and i'm gonna be all up in his stuff
and that's what it takes man you're not
gonna break something like this if you
don't because the there's a chemistry
that goes with this there's the
endorphin release the dopamine release
the high you get when you hit
when you actually win whatever it is
you're gambling whether you're sports
betting or whether you're playing cards
or with your online gambling whatever
you're doing you get a high on it
and it keeps you coming back
it keeps you coming back and uh that's
that's the addictive nature of it and
actually we're addicted in that case to
the chemicals in our own body
um but it's not out of your control and
you're not a victim to it and you don't
have to be this way you get to choose
but you've got to put some different
people in your life and your buddies
you've been hanging out with that think
this is cool they're off limits you got
to stop it
if you have a drinking problem you can't
run around your drinking buddies
and you're otherwise you're going to
have a drinking problem duh
you become who you hang around with man
you talk like them you walk like them
you read like them you go to church like
them you treat your wife like them
you become who you hang around with
and so you've got to put some people in
your life that are different than the
ones that have been in your life that
thought this was okay
and that's why i'm outlining like a
pastor
ga
a good counselor
and you're gonna write a check or two
for some of this stuff but again it's
going to be cheaper than
the gambling addiction
this is the problem
the downside
of the internet the internet is not evil
but access to porn
used to be
used to have to go to a lot of effort to
get to porn
now three clicks and you're in
four clicks and you're into stuff no
human should ever see
the accesses that the internet gives you
to betting
you know it's to the point that it's
like if you're not doing it you're not
cool because everybody's betting and if
you don't believe me watch the
commercials on every football game every
commercial break is two betting
commercials at least
this is tens of millions of dollars of
ad revenue
every night every time you turn on a
football game they don't give those
commercials away because by the way let
me help you with this broadcast
television has no one watching it
anymore
their ratings have evaporated
people watch on demand only
the only live television anyone is
watching
is the weather report on the local news
and live sporting events
the so the nfl ratings used to be the
largest thing during the playoffs and
they would beat the best sitcom on cbs
or the best movie of the week on nbc by
a few ratings points
now it's 10 and 20 and 30 x
because no one is watching that crap if
you've turned on broadcast television
lately and you had to try to watch a
movie and all the commercials keep
interrupting you and you get pissed off
that means you haven't watched broadcast
tv in a long time because that's why
it's always been
but you quit watching it and you started
watching on netflix on hulu you started
watching it and and this access
that it's giving you is is
it's devastating you guys
so the the the shift of the internet on
gambling addictive behaviors is very
real
and some of you that's your wake-up call
this little rant right here and jamie's
low problem is a whole bunch of people's
problem out there it's an explosion of
negative
consequences
and you guys have got to manage it for
your own lives you're not a victim of it
that puts us hour the ramsey show in the
books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit thermsyshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host
on the week where baby steps
millionaires the book how ordinary
people built extraordinary wealth and
how you can too becomes a number one
bestseller on all the major lists um
it's a good idea that we do a
millionaire theme hour a baby steps
millionaire theme hour now what's a
millionaire theme hour
a millionaire theme hour if you've never
listened to one of these is when i take
calls only from real millionaires
regardless of how you became a
millionaire if you inherited the money
you won the lotto uh you just signed an
nfl contract i don't care what it is
that made you a millionaire
we uh you've worked hard for 58 million
years i don't care what it is we want to
hear your story if you're a millionaire
you call me right now i want to teach
people all through the ramsey audience
what a millionaire really sounds like
and how they really got there by talking
to real ones
the point is that we're not talking to
people with an opinion
we're talking people who did it
my old pastor used to say a man with an
experience is not at the mercy of a man
with an opinion
so you're gonna be talking to people
with an experience they really are
millionaires the phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five two two five now some people don't
understand the real definition of a
millionaire there is only one definition
of a millionaire
the definition of a millionaire is when
you have a net worth
of one million dollars or more
your net worth is calculated very simply
by assets minus liabilities things you
own
minus debts you owe
is your net
worth
when your net worth is more than a
million dollars then and only then are
you a millionaire it is not you make a
million dollars a year
it is not
that you make a certain amount
well a million dollars isn't enough it's
not a moral construct evil rich people
are evil it's not a moral construct
it's not a
a million dollars isn't enough we can
discuss that we can talk about that but
that doesn't matter a millionaire is
still
a millionaire
now why does millionaire matter
why does a net worth of a million
dollars matter
because it's your first major
milestone in your wealth building
journey
after you've gotten yourself out of debt
so that you could actually start
building some wealth
you become a millionaire first then you
would be having a 5 million net worth a
10 million net worth or more some people
never get past that and that's fine
there's about 15 million millionaires in
north america
now we've run into people who became
millionaires with the baby steps and
that's why we call them baby steps
millionaires and this is a baby steps
millionaire theme hour some of these
people became millionaires while
listening to this show doing the things
that i teach some of them didn't they
just became millionaires other ways and
that's fine too we want to hear from
real millionaires to tell you folks what
a real millionaire is eric is our first
one
eric is in louisville kentucky eric what
is your net worth
right at a million dave right there man
all right cool and how old are you
35 years old young guy good man way to
go all right give me a little break down
on the million dollars the mix on it
yeah so it's about 600 a thousand
between both my wife's 401ks we have
another about a hundred thousand and
some iras
and then 300 000 in some real estate or
or equity in our home right and then
about another 75 000 um in cash good
good okay cool how much of this money
did you inherit
not a dumb uh just inherits some great
advice from both of our parents but uh
not a job okay and what has been your
range of income best year household
income and worst your household income
since you started your adult life
yeah since um we started uh probably
about right about 50 000 work our way up
to today to about 160.
okay what do you guys do for a living
we're both in sales and uh consumer
package good uh industries okay sales
rep four year degree
yeah uh mine was in a business marketing
and supply chain and my wife was in
communication okay what was your gpa
um mine said about 3.2 and i have to say
my length did feed me she's about 3.6
okay good all right good very good good
deal okay how much of this debt is or
this net worth is there because you
borrowed money and it cost you to become
wealthy
uh not a dom not a dime at all okay so
you didn't use nothing down real estate
or something like that you borrow money
to buy bitcoin or something like that
no sorry okay cool all right so what do
you tell
the 24 year old that's watching you and
me right now on youtube
uh the 23 year old that says how can i
be uh
how can i be eric when i grow up and i'm
35 10 years from now
what do they need to do
yeah a couple things that we live by
first is get around someone that will
teach you and not tell you
um uh secondly really run your own race
uh while living below your meaning i
mean say that first one again some get
around people that will what oh teach
you
teach you and not tell you okay all
right good i heard it now good
yes sir uh secondly
we always say just run your own race uh
while living below your means a lot of
times we see on social media it's a
great place for businesses and staying
connected to friends and family
but a lot of times you see things uh
that simply people are doing that they
can't afford uh so we always make sure
that we stay below our means
our living means and third uh you know
get out of debt
until you can really start investing
early and often you know compound
interest has been our best friends uh
throughout our working career um and
then lastly
you must have started your 401ks in at
what age
right
right at 22. yeah i mean as soon as you
got out of school you took your job you
started the 401 case
yes sir that's what we were talking
about it's paid off you know 35 years
old near a millionaire yeah yes sir
and then
yep and then the last thing we will
always just say is uh you know
philippians 4 19 says my god shall
supply all your means according to his
riches and though we truly believe in
giving
my wife and i have the last three years
been through uh countless of ibs and
trying to have a baby and during the
process we just continue to give and uh
trust in god and and now we're having a
baby uh this coming march in a couple
months wonderful
and helping others along the way we
believe all that comes back tenfold so
hey amen
amen are you guys tv people or book
people you read books or watch tv
i have to admit i'm the tv but my wife's
the book person okay
all right what's the best book either
one of you have read that's non-fiction
and not a dave ramsey book in the last
two years
well my new year's my new year's
resolution looks to do a little reading
so right now i just heard the tower
broke uh by damon john actually oh yeah
okay
damon's become a friend that's a cool
book good very good good stuff man
congratulations eric all right we're
talking to real millionaires on a baby
steps millionaires theme hour if you
listen to these folks you'll hear how
they did it the reason i'm doing this is
so you can do it and so you can believe
you can do it because you hear your
story in theirs
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit
whether you do it yourself or you have
them measure and install everything for
you shop their latest looks and see how
much you can save at blinds.com today
the easy and affordable way to make your
home more beautiful is blinds.com
[Music]
well it's time to put 2021 behind us
last year left a lot of people feeling
burned out and sluggish
a lot of us did a lot of whining i was
on the list eeyore was our spirit animal
right
but 2022 is a fresh start it's our
wake-up call we're going to be ready to
own this year actually accomplish our
goals you can make 2022 your best year
ever and we're running our new year's
sale right now and you can get 73 off
our best-selling books assessments and
envelopes includes the brand new book
number one bestseller baby steps
millionaires that'll show you the
quickest right way to become a
millionaire or if you're looking for a
better way to manage your cash
especially in categories that always
blow up your budget like food pick up
our essential cash envelope systems
maybe you're having a hard time bouncing
back from the last two wild years you
can check out the best-selling quick
read by dr john delony redefining
anxiety it's only 10 bucks right now all
kinds of sales all kinds of good things
all
kinds of tools to help you check it all
out at
ramseysolutions.com in the store
ramseysolutions.com in the store it's a
millionaire a baby steps millionaire
theme hour we're talking to real
millionaires regardless of how they
became a millionaire so you can hear
what it sounds like to hit that first
milestone
of wealth building peggy is with us
peggy's in athens georgia hi peggy
what's your net worth
our net worth is 1.3 million and i have
my husband jamie here as well he's just
overhearing the conversation awesome
well congratulations you guys all right
how old are you
um i'm 54 and my husband is 45. okay
cool now give me a little breakdown of
the mix of the 1.3 million net worth
what categories is it in
uh we have about 50 percent in roth iras
so 650 in roth
okay uh 19 in tsp so about
242 okay and 31 in cash okay
and so
what does that come out about 400 um
yeah 461. what about your house
um so we currently don't own a home oh
you don't
we're camp hosting right now but uh
we're actually in the process of
purchasing we just sold a house in west
virginia moved back to georgia
and uh that's why you're sitting on so
much cash yeah okay yes so how much of
this 1.3 million did you guys inherit
oh that would be zero zero and your best
year household income since you got
married and your worst year
household income since you got married
uh worst year was the year we got
married so that would be about 44 000.
best year was 2008 was 150 000. cool
what do y'all do for a living
well we're retired now we're both
retired military i retired from the navy
he retired from the army oh well thank
you for your service either one of you
have four-year degrees
yes we both do actually i have two and
he has one okay what's your degree in
um
information technology and accounting
for me
and wildlife management for my husband
got it and what were your gpas
uh anywhere from 3.5 to 4-0 okay all
right somewhere in there all right good
good okay cool
thank you for your service and i i now
know why that there's 200 000 in that
tsp that was during the military time
that you're putting money in that
retirement plan
so good stuff very good stuff way to go
what do you tell
the youngsters that are listening if
they want to be you when they grow up
they're 25 or 30 years younger than you
and they're listening you could talk to
the young version of you out there just
going into the military can they become
a millionaire and if they can how should
they go about it
absolutely they can number one don't buy
the new car as soon as you graduate out
of boot camp
or the academies or however you get
there
budgeting of course is is important
as soon as you can start investing grant
you know determining being debt free and
stuff like that
the tsp now matches for
people coming in so
you know it's a it's a
free money yeah absolutely cool
cool good deal
so um how does it make you feel when
people say that there's no millionaires
or there's no wealthy people unless they
inherited their
money well we we know it can be done
um but they're you know there are a lot
of naysayers and you know you try and
explain the plan and say hey if you
follow it it works and you can be where
we are just working the normal job yeah
yeah i mean you never made a bazillion
dollars you make 500 000 a year or
something you just save money stayed out
of debt and worked you know you know
worked a plan and did you have a good
life while you're doing all that or did
you just sacrifice only and have no fun
well we we did sacrifice the first year
we started this i went to iraq for a
year and that's where that
huge bump in uh money came from because
the first year after i retired i went
and did that and that
uh
jump started our debt-free journey
because by that at that point we weren't
debt-free yet so you took a civilian
contractor thing after retiring in iraq
i did for one year what'd you make
that was the 150 about 100 yeah it was
about a hundred thousand yeah that was a
year you all made 150 though okay
way to go kiddo very proud of you great
job excellent excellent excellent
danielle is next in phoenix danielle
what's your net worth
hi grace can you hear me yes ma'am
yes my net worth is 1.3 million good
okay give me that a breakdown by
category on that
okay retirement consists of thrift
savings plan a traditional roth a
traditional ira and a roth ira an amount
of 494 494 000
okay
i have a couple of brokerage accounts um
worth
187 000
and
savings and checkings is 574
thousand dollars i just sold a house so
ah okay
okay and then that adds up to 1.3 good
how old are you
i am 45 years young good good are you
married
no sir okay how much how much of this
money did you inherit
well my husband passed away 10 years ago
so i i inherited a house and um his
traditional um ira so maybe a quarter of
a million
i'm not sure if we call that an
inheritance for this discussion or not
this is
i mean technically i guess it's an
inheritance but it's not like you had a
rich uncle that made you a millionaire
no sir now you and your husband were
saving money he passed away you got you
know you had combined assets so
okay what happened to him
um he accept this like blood poisoning
and um he just had some bad bad habits
wow i'm sorry
i'm sorry thank you so what is your best
year of household income since you got
out of school in your worst year of
household income since you got out of
school i would say last year was my best
um 116 and my worst would be when i
first got out of college at 31 000. okay
what do you do for a living
i am a government um worker and i also
am medically retired from the military
okay what do you do for the government
um i work with veterans okay good good
okay good work all right yes sir and uh
what's your do you have a four-year
degree
i do i do what's it in
psychology psych okay
and um what was your gpa
2.91 i was a student athlete so it was
tough okay cool what what sport did you
play
i played basketball okay for who
um university of notre dame all right
big time
big time program yeah good for you d1
look at you yes sir that's fun fun
so uh
looking out and you're sitting and going
back to your old high school
and they tell you in that high school
all people from this neighborhood they
can't they can't make it
and you're going to go on stage and tell
them they can make it right
yes sir what do you tell them they need
to do
[Music]
i would tell them you can do anything
that you put your mind to
establish goals early on at seven years
old i knew i wanted to go to the
university of notre dame if you can have
someone else pay for your your schooling
bachelor's degree graduate degree so you
can come out oh ain't no one that's the
quickest way to build wealth amen
ding ding all right we're talking to
real millionaires it's a baby steps
millionaires theme hour
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a baby steps millionaires theme
hour
too many people in america today are
beating the drum that the wealthy
or evil
that they are doing something wrong in
order to become
wealthy that only crooked people become
wealthy
or that the only way to become wealthy
is to inherit your wealth
or that the wealthy are always famous
people like entertainers or rock stars
or
athletes or that they're brilliant that
they have unusually high intellect
4.2 gpas
we did the largest study
of millionaires
ever done in north america
airtight research
it was no confirmation bias
i defy you to find anything wrong with
the research if you know anything about
research
we brought in a research company they
combined with the folks on our ramsey
research team to make sure that it was
airtight because we knew
some of you that have a leftist
socialist agenda in your brain
wouldn't believe us
and you still won't believe us even
though we can prove it
because you've already made up your mind
that you are going to believe a lie
the truth is
that 79 percent of the millionaires in
north america today inherited zero
another five percent
inherited a very small amount not enough
to help them become a millionaire like
their grandmother left them five
thousand dollars
another five percent inherited
substantial money
after they were already millionaires
five and five and 79 is 89.
of america's millionaires are not
millionaires because of an inheritance
that's 9 out of 10.
so when you tell people that wealth is
all trapped in certain families you are
what's known as a liar
you have believed a lie
by definition
this is not an opinion
this is data
it's known as a fact
and when you tell people that
all millionaires are unusually wealthy
are unusually brilliant not a fact
the average gpa of the millionaires that
we surveyed was right around 3.0
by the way mine was 2.97 and i'm still
pissed off about the three one
hundredths of a point
and when you tell people that all
wealthy people are crooks that just
shows that all you are is jealous
and envious
these are some of the seven deadly sins
if you ask my catholic friends
if you live your life as a victim
that is envious and jealous
you will never amount to anything
and so the point of the millionaire
theme hour the point of doing the
millionaires national millionaire study
the point of the book we published by
chris hogan called everyday millionaires
the point of a new book that i just did
baby steps millionaires about
millionaires that followed the baby
steps that i teach
all three of these pieces of information
are very very clear they don't cancel
each other out they're not to replace
each other
they are all solid pieces of information
we put the study the white paper on the
study in the back of the baby steps
millionaire's book so you would have it
and we show you mathematically
with facts
how you can do it why do we do all this
because we have learned that if you
think you can or you think you can't
you're right
henry ford said
if you really believe that the systems
in america are so broken that people
like you
whatever that means can't get ahead
then you are believing a victim
narrative
fed to you
by the people around you
and it's a lie
because the real narrative the real
storyline is that you can become a
millionaire in america today
anthony proved that he's in washington
d.c what's your net worth anthony
uh 2.6 million good for you and break
that down for me a little bit by
category please how much in each
category
well majority of it uh about 80 is in
our retirement account
okay i don't need percentages how much
is that
oh uh 2.1 million okay 2.1 million in
retirement all right and the other 500
000 is in what
uh there's 400 000
um we have like 300 000
of value in our
house and another 150 000 in outside
investments
and
um
a small portion of cash for emergency
funds gotcha how old are you
55 how much of this money did you
inherit
all of none
zero okay and what has been your
enduring your working lifetime what was
your best year household income and your
worst your household income
well we started off uh in 1991 we got
married around 35k
and
it averaged out over the years about
over a little over 100k okay good good
for you all right and what was your
career
uh i was an i.t specialist
and my wife is an intel specialist
oh very good okay and what is your
four-year degree in
computer science for morgan state
university
good for you
okay what was your gpa
uh 3.0
okay very good right on there okay so
let me ask you this was anybody in your
family millionaires before did what made
you think you could do this
uh nobody in my family was a millionaire
i didn't have any friends that were
millionaires
uh the thing was i
liked finances so i was interested in
finances
but i constantly got myself in debt
um
we
used the house to help pay off debt and
uh took out money out on 401k
so the thing that helped us was a
financial peace university
so she financed the peace university
were able to you know pay off all our
debt with the snowball
we um got a reserve-based budget and
just started putting 50 to a retirement
account so right now we're on baby step
father six
okay they're showing you the pictures of
your beautiful family on youtube
and uh so let me ask you this you uh i
want you to speak to the
african-american community about this
because i think there's a real narrative
there that we you and i need to tell the
story that you can do this
right
and that's one of the things um
you need to find people who are doing
what you're doing
um
and that
one of the key things because um
you know
and so that's what i kind of try to put
myself around people who were trying to
you know build their finances and get
things correct correct i think the thing
that for me
was that i didn't have a good roadmap
and that's what i think financial peace
did it give you a good roadmap
to avoid the pitfalls of life
and kind of steer you in the right
direction
and so i try to tell everybody get on
financial peace
uh i coordinate financial peace i've
been doing it for the weekend thank you
thank you
so i am sure
that in your life of 55 years you have
faced racism
yes
and you've overcome that to have a 2.6
million dollar net worth
yes yeah
because i get i guess it just didn't
define you you just decided i'm going to
do math because math is not racist
this is not correct yeah and you know
you
you
overcome i know you just got to overcome
certain things you know you can't let
that define you or stop you from going
where you want to go yeah amen i'm so
proud of you man and thank you for
teaching financial peace i'm honored to
have you as a coordinator you're an
incredible incredible man very very well
done sir you're an absolute hero for
your family you've changed everything in
everyone's life around you by taking
control of this
very well done
that's what these millionaires do people
they come from every walk of life and
background
so you can too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today hebrews 6 19 we have
this hope as an anchor for the soul
firm and secure
albert einstein said learn from
yesterday live for today hope for
tomorrow the important thing
is to not stop questioning
baby steps millionaires is a number one
best-selling book thank you america you
did that you bought it we appreciate it
uh we appreciate our team and all the
hard work they put on it this is a baby
steps millionaires theme hour where
we're talking to real millionaires adam
is in detroit adam what is your net
worth
dave it's 1.7 million for myself and my
wife excellent and give me a little
breakdown by category please how much in
each category
so we have 50 000 cash we have 1.3
million in the stock market which would
be mutual funds and index funds
we have 90 000 in 529 for our two kids
and then we have
roughly 200 000 in real estate equity
which is split between our primary house
in a small cottage
and then 100 000 in cars and
miscellaneous assets good for you how
old are you
38 and my wife is 40. excellent very
good how much of this 1.7 million net
worth did you inherit
uh none
cool and your range of income your best
year working and worst you're working
yep so
uh starting in 2007
combined we would have been roughly 60
000.
um we've averaged over these last 15
years
145 000
and
our income has grown these last few
years so we're in the high 200s right
now
okay all right cool good for you all
right and what you're in uh what's your
career
uh so i i work in commercial real estate
and my wife is a social worker very good
and do you have a four-year degree
i do a bachelor's in finance and then my
wife has
a bachelor's in psychology and a
master's in social work
good and what was your gpa
so i did have a high gpa so i was 3.97
and then my
wife was roughly 3.5 okay good for you
well done
good job man good job so can this still
be done you're 38 years old you're
talking to a 20
uh what a 23 year old 15 years your
junior
can they still do it
yeah with without a doubt i think
there's more opportunities than ever to
be an entrepreneur
and really although i always did a good
job of budgeting and staying out of debt
um i woke up at 27 so about 12 years ago
and we had not saved anything for
retirement so
i think
the biggest keys i think is if you're
gonna be get married marry a spouse that
has
the same financial mindset as you it's
just it's so critical to be on the same
page
don't purchase too much house it's going
to be the biggest purchase you make and
and that's going to drive how much
you're able to save and invest
and then maintain the same lifestyle as
your income grows that's probably been
the the biggest driver in our wealth
building is we still live in the same
starter house that we bought 12 years
ago when you were making 60 and now
you're making almost 300 yeah
yeah way to go adam great job man that's
how it's done ding ding 38 year old
millionaire uh jeremy's with us in
austin texas jeremy what's your net
worth
uh one point hi dave uh
1.08 so about a million eighty-five
thousand okay good give me a little
breakdown by category how much in each
category
sure 815 in different mutual funds roth
ira 401k
uh about 50 000 in cash uh about 220 in
home equity good all right good for you
how old are you
50. all right good
and how much of this did you inherit
well
there was an inheritance day that a
thousand dollars one thousand dollars
don't think you're a millionaire because
of that okay you're right
excellent and your range of income best
working year worst you're working your
household income
so i i stumbled out of the starting gate
in my 20s so it was like 15 000 starting
out and now it is much closer to 200
last year good good what do you do for a
living
uh work as an analyst in defense related
stuff okay
all right and do you have a four-year
degree
i do i had a history degree so uh
liberal arts you can still you can still
get ahead in this country even with
liberal arts all right good
and your gpa was what
uh 3-2 undergrad okay good good all
right well if you're an analyst you
probably probably historical
uh the history major gave you some
perspectives when you're doing some of
your analyst work right
absolutely absolutely it helped me in
graduate school as well so i do have a
master's degree
as well okay good for you way to go
all right man excellent okay can someone
do this you're 50 years old can someone
who's 25 still become a millionaire
absolutely dave i think one of the worst
things is that society's constant
negative messaging that is not possible
for you i mean i grew up as a single
parent in public housing and uh latino
to boot and all of those things oh you
shouldn't be able to do it it's possible
it's harder for some people than for
others no doubt
we all have different obstacles but it's
possible uh and uh drives me crazy when
i hear that negative messaging that it's
not um
so what's your latino heritage
uh mexico okay so you your mom's a
single mexican lady raising kids
do i know my uh dad was latino mom anglo
oh okay okay cool all right but mom
raised you
and and as a single mom and you come out
of that household in that situation and
you're a millionaire at 50.
yeah i'm proud of you man well done it's
a great american dream
to control your own destiny i'm so proud
of you very very well done
okay so
we had 1 million net worth 1.3 1.3 2.6
1.7 1.1
precisely zero
of them became millionaires because of
an inheritance there were 35 54
45 55 38 and 50.
none of them were 80
none of them had a horrible life because
they didn't do anything they never had
any fun they stayed home and only went
out on triple coupon thursday and
collected lent that's none of them did
any of that they all had good lives
they've all been saving steadily and got
their house paid off
standard
all these things fit the exact
guidelines of what we found when we
studied millionaires
and there's about 15 million of them
that as best we can tell i'm beginning
to think there's more
out there
um
but listen 38
35 years old calling in
that's ridiculous y'all i mean we used
to say millionaires are reserved for
somebody in their 60s
but you guys are doing this at record
paces
uh because you're
you're plugging into your 401ks you're
getting your houses paid off you're
avoiding debt you're living on a plan
you're working together with your spouse
for those of you that are married you're
not using get rich quick
you're using steady
because get rich quick doesn't work
it you don't end up rich
when the story's over that's the thing
it always ends up in the in a bad story
the end of the story is always negative
it's always sad
and we don't want you to be sad we want
you to win
if get rich quick worked i'd tell you to
do it if it was the if it was the thing
we found in the millionaire study that
hey everybody in the millionaire study
used bitcoin i would tell you to go get
bitcoin
if everybody in the study used nothing
down real estate scams to
go go get rich and they they remained
rich throughout their whole lives and
they didn't go broke from it i would
tell you to go do that
if they all bought gold i would tell you
to go buy gold did you hear anybody say
they got rich on bitcoin or gold today
there was open phones anybody can call
that's a millionaire
but nobody did
did you hear anybody say that they got
rich but with a lottery
they quit buying stupid lottery tickets
that's stupid
come on
think people
seriously
do the stuff that works that's why we
put it right in front of you we don't
want you to mess up we love you we want
you to win
we love you so much that we'll call you
stupid when you're stupid that's how
much we love you
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you